alors avec nos joueuses et alec et
christian pour le panel politique
bonsoir vous 3 au soir soit vous avez vu
ce sont vous savez pas ce que vous
suivez sa com comme des maniaques de
politique les sondages le sait ça peut
pas être plus ericsson et avec les
marges d'erreur et 50 circonscriptions à
surveiller cet énorme dans une soirée
électorale au canada d'une part d'avoir
35 36 des fois puis le reste on s'est
pas mal l'alec 1,50 et beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'endroits dont georges hier
monsieur legault j'ai fait un détour par
les sondages on revient monsieur legault
tour de table josée legault
comment vous avez compris cette
intervention comme en grèce et muscler
ce matin monsieur legault en faveur d'un
gouvernement minoritaire conservateur de
l'inquiétude de l'inquiétude justement
pour faire suite au sondage
à cause de cette petite remontée récente
des libéraux le fait que la cour soit en
effet ou si serré et que la performance
des red hot où l'eau dernier débat
d'hier soir en français étaient plutôt
disons est spectaculaire c'est moins
qu'on puisse dire et monsieur trudeau
lui quand même été assez bons donc c'est
d'inquiétude j'ai vu de l'inquiétude de
se retrouver possiblement face à un
autre gouvernement minoritaire libéral
et là il a décidé en son for intérieur
de st géry directement dans la campagne
fédérale alec
ça me choque pris cette soirée là ça m'a
surpris parce qu'un grosso modo il a
répété ce qu'il a dit il ya deux
semaines avec des mots beaucoup plus dur
peut-être qu'à de françois legault était
déçu un peu que l'effet de sa sortie à
deux semaines soit pas aussi fracassant
qui l'aurait espéré donc à neuf rajouter
une couche aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression
qu'il a dépensé du capital politique
aujourd'hui françois legault parce que
c'est pas comme si les gens qui avait vu
renault tour lors des deux précédents
débats s'était amourachée de lui
soudainement ils traînent des casseroles
depuis le début de la campagne sur les
armes à feu sur les changements
climatiques sont son entente avec les
garderies au québec qu'il veut abroger
et que françois legault simple as aussi
clairement dans son camp même si c'est
pour encore brit air oui le beaucoup de
capital de sympathie et françois legault
donc peut-être décidé d'en dépenser un
peu aujourd'hui mais je suis pas certain
qu'il ya bien des québécois qui ont
écouté ce puits se sont pas dit ah c'est
un peu étrange j'ai pas l'impression
nécessairement que j'ai le goût - de
suivre françois legault me dis je vais
presque peut-être quelques québécois à
rebrousse poil aujourd'hui qu'ils
avaient plus d'intentions de vote et
bloque plus l'intention de voter libéral
pour ça que je dis que peut-être
peut-être forcé la note un peu
aujourd'hui françois legault le show
tout jose raison lendemain du débat pour
une auto qui était très ordinaire on lui
fait une grosse fleur et renault tous
les jours de vue chez lui au cabinet de
françois legault christian je pense que
c'est très intéressant en fait que la
prise de position de monsieur legault
c'est potentiellement majeur voire
historique même peut-être parce que le
timing ans ce soir au débat en anglais
la pollution mais c'est le gris très
très très clair très ferme donc je sais
pas jusqu'à quel point monsieur au tour
va être capable de l'utiliser monsieur
legault est quand même l'homme politique
que le plus de crédibilité au canada
actuellement il peut prétendre parler
beaucoup au nom des québécois ces taux
d'application sont à 50 % et son
argumentaire est solide comme du roc son
argumentaire c'est le pouvoir québécois
jugent que monsieur o'toole en fait est
celui qui défend le mieux le power
québécois ce qui est intéressante au
delà de la game politique
précise voyons la forêt c'est que
monsieur o'toole a clairement tendu la
main au cul au québec et monsieur
legault prend la main de monsieur
o'toole et on peut se demander une
feuille de match me laisse me laisse
passer parce qu'il faut avoir le plaisir
aussi de réfléchir est ce qu'il n'ya pas
de possibilité de reconstitution de lax
ouest québec qui était à la base des
conservateurs vous résumer aux
mauresques nos sens que j'en rêve mais
j'ai pensé à ça un moment donné parce
que monsieur gosselin bleus
fondamentalement c'est un conservateur
bleus il ya comme c'est pas étonnant
qu'ils fassent et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que des mecs québec versus reste
du canada l'homme peut influer sur
l'autre n'oublions jamais que les
vecteurs aux québécois et extrêmement
volatile
on a vu tout à l'heure que québécois
sont pas encore décidés les québécois
john voter massivement plus
conservateurs ayant voté massivement les
néo-démocrates et moi je n'exclus pas si
l élection qui est du mouvement
autrement dit si monsieur hutus au
tourisme et à progresser un peu normal
facteurs maxime bernier qui peut lui
nuire baux courant parce que maxime
bernier très élevé mais là on voyait là
vous les gars grands mouvements comme il
ya déjà eu ben oui à la reprise en soi
puisqu'elle est ce que j'ose dire c'est
que si maintenant dans la semaine
prochaine on réalise qu autour de leur
parti pour l'emporter moi je n'exclus
pas que les québécois qu'ils aillent
voter du bon bord sans dire que je suis
veulent se mettre qu'un mouvement
beaucoup plus fort qu'en fait c'est pour
ça que je trouve moi je serai content
mme ebadi garderie parce que c'est ça
qui est ça les gars de risques et je
vais finir en parlant d' ami rabir et
acquisitions et les garderies donc
monsieur legault en fait absous qu'un
certain point la grosse faute de
monsieur o toole en ce qui a trait aux
garderies et o'toole qui à présent à
l'égard de cuba qui a réussi l'essentiel
you pas impressionné les commentateurs
il n'a pas impressionné mes collègues
sauf que pas des plus y croire il ya pas
sucé d'animosité doit donc trouve que ça
plusieurs chantiers les chefs christian
josé josé on
va pas te josé est à l'aise sur les
garderies c'est quand même parce que
christian utilise le absoudre et c'est
exactement ça il a dit ce matin web on
n'est pas très contents mais tout de
suite après il revenait sur monsieur
trudeau donc on a l'impression qu'ils en
disent voir jouer à régler sommes en
même temps 6 milliards pour les gars de
risque assez concret se jauger oui c'est
ça il rbra qu'est continuellement les
projecteurs sur le site rideau qui la
turquie est très très très durement et
sur monsieur au tour ce qui est là où je
suis d'accord avec avec alex et moi
aussi je pense que même s'il ya
énormément de capital politique a
dépassé il y en a dépensé une partie ce
matin parce que justement le parti
conservateur d'un autour ce n'est pas le
parti conservateur de brian mulroney
s'est encore le parti conservateur de
stephen harper et stephen harper en 2006
il y avait aussi le coût de la grande
séduction au québec l'ouverture la
décentralisation
mais pendant les dix ans où il a été là
c'était des gestes essentiellement
symbolique qui a pas eu vraiment de
substance et monsieur legault dit
rechercher une plus grande autonomie
pour le québec quand il se dit
nationaliste et se dit aussi
autonomistes et qui dit autonomie 10 et
large issement à des poids du québec
comporte pas seulement dessous le
d'argent on parle aussi d'élargissement
des pouvoirs et monsieur autour est à la
tête d'un gouvernement qui est
pancanadien qui a des intérêts partage
encore beaucoup vers l'ouest c'est un
père dont beaucoup vers l'ouest canadien
beaucoup d intérêt encore pro industrie
pétrolière et cetera une base où il ya
beaucoup de militaires qui sont
climato-sceptiques qui sont contre le
droit d je veux juste terminer son
compte le droit des femmes à
l'avortement alors s'est il choisir
qu'un premièrement ça constitue une
ingérence d'un premier ministre
provincial en politique fédérale mais il
choisit un cas qui ne plaît pas
nécessairement et qui ne raconte pas
nécessairement les les autres valeurs
fondamentales de beaucoup de québécois
il faut que le nationalisme il ya des
valeurs aussi sociale en verre en vers
en mai chaque jour c'est incontestable
ah c'est sûr que ça les conservateurs y
compris à l'époque de stephen harper a
envahi c'est beaucoup moins les
compétences provinciales chauve que la
position de françois legault atteint dr
keith de quad est extrêmement solide ça
me semble incontestable que les
conservateurs de rhinau tour vont - en
fait s'attaquer aux compétences
québécoise que les libéraux et ça c'est
du vc très bien quand même et c est ce
qu on peut juste se rappeler que c'est
quand même avec des gouvernements
libéraux fédéraux que mais monsieur
bouchard négocier des choses
intéressantes bien sur le plan
constitutionnel et dans les derniers
mois c'est ça qui est un peu surréaliste
matin françois legault et justin trudeau
qui était rendu à tu et à toi on négocie
aussi d
sur les services de garde monsieur
legault a réussi à avoir 6 milliards
sans condition il le répéter il peut
dépenser où il veut il peut en prendre
un pour le troisième bien il peut des
bases et où ils veulent et 6 milliards
et là un mois après dire je reçois
comment comprenez ça
le 6 milliards il ya 750 millions pour
l'aérospatiale il ya un demi milliard
pour l'internet haute vitesse il ya de
l'argent pour les batteries debussy lyon
les voitures électriques dans le camp de
françois de justin trudeau aujourd'hui
l'on doit trouver que notre ami dira pas
si longtemps compris beaucoup de temps
de renverser sa chemise donc on a dû
trouver ça un peu fort et si vous
vouliez avoir une idée du fait que les
autres partis à l'assemblée nationale
ont aussi penser qu'aujourd'hui françois
legault avait fait une sortie un petit
peu spécial regardez la réaction du
parti libéral du québec solidaire qui
ont vu tout de suite eu l'opportunité
divin nous les garderies le réseau des
garderies on veut les complète ont vu le
compléter on veut donner des places aux
jeunes les familles ont besoin de
nouvelles places on veut l'argent
d'ottawa françois legault est dans le
champ avec son appui à un auto donc même
à l'assemblée nationale on prépare
l'élection dans un an puis
je veux absolument vous parlez par
ailleurs de cette prise de bec qui aère
de ce moment il y en a eu heureusement
il y en a eu quelques-uns
monsieur un trudeau et monsieur blanchet
on va écouter donc un extrait du débat
sur le québec sur qui défend le mieux
est le monsieur trudeau s'est senti
attaqué à trois raisons plei a eu ceci
mais s'il faut poser aux nations
autochtones quoi faire ou quoi penser
pourquoi d'ici là la nation québécoise
quoi faire et quoi penser parce que je
suis québécois monsieur blanchet
je suis fier québécois que j'ai toujours
été québécois que je serai toujours
québécois et je suis là avec mon mot à
dire vous avez pas le l'unanimité sur
sur le québec on est plusieurs à
représentent ils
je peux vous dire monsieur blanchette
des matrices de
lenche est que vous ne voulez pas
s'aimer les gérants ce que tu fais les
âges
prenez l'avis du gouvernement comme
étant le vôtre c'est des contradictions
profondes mais non vous me poserez pas
d'être aux québécois monsieur blanchet
bondeko s'élevait à ce moment-là
[Rires]
débat
noble en quittant avec les chemins et il
a même une confrontation
oui alors qu'avez vous pensé de sa
tour de table rapide s'il vous plaît
christian franc avec vous de scouts ici
bas je pense que monsieur trudeau bien
fait de répliquer québécoises et
québécois comme monsieur blanchette
c'est clair mais moi ce que j'ai retenu
c'est que nos deux fier québécois en ce
qui a trait à la sauvegarde du
bilinguisme au clan canadien se sont
effondrés alors kérino tous les deux
langues officielles au canada en réponse
au québec comme moi j'avais demandé est
ce que vous seriez puis s'ils n'en
connaissent en fait les langues
autochtones comme officiel au canada
monsieur trudeau pas signer en disant
qu'ils étaient fiers d'avoir nommé un
gouverneur général qui parlait pas
français qui parlent autochtone et
monsieur blanchette et se jetant bien
beau de ma chaise pour moi ça a été
l'élément le plus important du débat
monsieur blanchette a consentis au
niveau fédéral à ce qu'on reconnaisse
officiellement les langues autochtones
ce qui ne nuirait pas d'anglès qui
n'eurent essentiellement français je
suis étonné que personne n au tessin
donc ce sont deux fier québécois mais
ceux qui défendent le bilinguisme au
niveau fédéral hier c'est terry mootools
à porter l'odieux fier québécois alec
je pense que justin trudeau attendait le
moment pour pouvoir effectivement dit
que les québécois lui aussi que
plusieurs courants au québec et que donc
on n'y a pas un seul parti qui parle
pour l'ensemble du québec parce que
quand on regarde la fin de la tirade de
francs deux êtres d'où ils vous
m'excuserez pas d'un poète québécois
mais c'est parce qu'ils france oblige
dit non plus donc on sent qu on sent que
ça le piqué au vif pour vrai je pense
mais je pense qu'il avait hâte de
pouvoir rappeler qu'il est québécois et
billets peut-être aller un petit peu
loin et même temps dans une soirée où il
n'y avait pas beaucoup d'étincelles ses
classes à les retenir l'attention je
peux vous dire que les troupes libérales
au québec ont bien noté la ferveur de
leurs chefs ça leur fait plaisir
ce n'est que ça il y aura atteint son
but mais je pense qu'il avait hâte de
pouvoir la place et celle de julien put
sur l'environnement sur les garderies a
eu des moments de vie on y reviendra
josé
j'ai vu deux choses la première j'ai
fait à mon âge avancé j'ai entendu un
peu les coups de son père mais en moins
baveux évidemment au référendum de 1980
un des slogans du camp du non c'était
mon nom no1 et québécois et ça c'est
peter rappelle très important la
deuxième chose c'est l' agacement je
pense qu'ils commencent à gagner pour
seulement le parti libéral du canada
mais d autres partis aussi à la chambre
des communes face à yves françois
blanchet contraire mais j'ai du serbe
dans le passé à la tête du bloc s'arroge
vrai mal le titre de défenseur unique et
suprême ultime du québec la nation et
des intérêts du québec bon alors c'est
sûr que c'est un petit peu sage a passé
hier soir aussi qui est sorti dans ses
créations
débord 21 heures ce soir les gens m'ont
dit ça coûte aux rebelles des bambins
oui c'est comme ça nos derniers en
anglais avec noms viennent faire le
point avec philippe j avec le
niveau des sondages et c'est de la
course qui très très serré qu'est ce que
vous allez surveiller ce soir je
commence avec vous changez tour de table
je surveillais à une auto bien entendu
parce que bon en français tout le monde
l'a remarqué c'est quand même y est il
très robotique qui est très
vraiment script est là donc on va voir
s'ils veulent réussir à être un petit
peu plus humain s'il va avoir un peu
plus de passion et s'ils vont enfin
pouvoir expliquer son au plat un petit
peu mieux et et justin trudeau qui je
pense va lui aussi être particulièrement
énergique avec un
auto clairement le plus à perdre ce soir
parce que ça monte elle est terminée il
au mieux il stagne dans les sondages
n'ont régressé un peu les libéraux sont
à remonter c'est ce qui fait qu'on est
au coude à coude dans les sondages
actuellement donc doit absolument avoir
un godet bol ça fait une semaine qu'il
est sur la défensive sur les armes à feu
sur les garderies au québec il ya il
peut prendre les six derniers jours le
voulait jeter à la poubelle c'est énorme
dans une campagne de 36 jours et l'on
qui doit absolument roduit ce soir le
faire un meilleur des bop et jack
meeting doit être un peu moins facile
ynwa il doit comme un outil capable
d'expliquer son plan la compassion c'est
bien l'empathie c'est bien non c'est
toujours parce que le npd veut offrir à
qui que ce soit là il faudrait que ce
soit un peu plus clair rasseoir pour les
détails oui il ya un très fière
d'internés beaucoup plus souvent jeunes
et gelé trop était christian jeanjean
souriez monsieur où tous le voir s'il va
être capable de faire quelque chose du
cadeau de monsieur legault un appui
aussi clair en fait ce premier ministre
du québec ce qui est à survivre
d'amasser plus de thériault qui va être
visée toronto qui va être visé ce que
les les numéros vont être capables de
faire peur en fait aux gens qui sont
anti droite et néo-démocrates ans
d'écouter votre pad et aux démocrates
parce qu'il ya un risque sérieux de
gouvernements conservateurs c'est clair
que ça va être crucial ce soir parce que
ça peut tout peut arriver en fait
madame paule il reste quelques secondes
à la pole hier c'est bon c'est première
maman ou le grand public alors qu'est ce
que vous avez trouvé josé qu'est ce qui
vous vient à l'esprit
mais c'était trop peu trop tard d'une
certaine manière on n'a pas vu au québec
du tout de la campagne s'est cantonné
dans son comté à peu près tout le temps
il ya eu quelques bonnes interventions
dont justement sur les services de garde
cela dit s'ils avaient eu plus de femmes
peut-être que oui puis d'ailleurs au
québec ça vient de pauline marois
ce qu'elles avaient elles avaient très
bon point mais à part de ça a été je
pense qu'elle est
on débat hier à sacha pardon en sachant
qu'elle n'avait absolument rien à gagner
au québec dont on va se laisser là
dessus moi j'ai fait leur dire aux
marnais fusionner parce que le pdf il
était d'accord sur coup hier ils
arrêtent pas dire où je suis d'accord il
était à côté l'un de l'autre merci
beaucoup à vous trois très bientôt au
revoir ce conflit pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit